[Music]
ever since Camila Cabello when Shawn
Mendes is steaming music video for
senorita dropped there's been one big
question on everyone's mind are they
dating here's what we know the bear has
been spending a lot of time together
hanging out in LA showing off lots of
PDA but a source tells ET jameelah
actually isn't a couple at all we're
told Camila and Shawn have always been
close friends they work on music
together and did mire each other but
Camila just got out of a relationship
and Shawn is on tour so the duo isn't
looking to get into anything serious
right now quite simply our source says
increasing the seriousness of their
relationship will be hard
[Music]
jameelah dating rumors are hardly a new
topic in fact the rumor mill has been on
fire ever since they first linked up in
2015 and dropped their first collab
[Music]
they address the speculation on The Late
Late Show with James Corden are you two
dating now no okay don't believe you
there's no way you haven't made out
we're and again a month later with et
the record straight
no we are just friends right Assange
we're not dating can we invite you guys
to write more songs together
she's amazing like super talented his
songwriter I've never worked with the
extra songwriter who I clicked with as
well as her so definitely